- [Brandon] Go.
(upbeat music)
- [Regina] We're gonna go to
29Rooms of Instagram heaven.
- Instagram is pretty much my job.
- So if you haven't seen his face before,
You've probably definitely
seen his Instagram.
He shoots really really really cool,
aesthetically-pleasing photos.
My relationship with Instagram,
I love it, but I don't think it loves me.
- I haven't seen your profile.
We need to check it out.
These are good, but I can
definitely help you out.
Let's do it.
- We made it to...
- [Brandon] 29Rooms.
- [Regina Voiceover] 29Rooms is a popup
here in Williamsburg, New York,
and it's a huge funhouse of 29 different,
aesthetically-pleasing
rooms that were made
to be put on your Instagram.
- I really like the disco ball room.
I wouldn't stay away from that.
Do you wanna put on some glasses?
You wanna make it happen?
- Do you have glasses?
- [Brandon] I do have them.
Ooh, we're getting some yellow vibes.
So fun, see they're all so different.
- [Regina] It's so fricking cool.
- [Brandon] Those look cool.
See, the glasses, I feel
like adds a little- (snaps)
- [Regina] The glasses definitely
add a little something.
- Ooh, wait, I like these colors.
I was like, "Wait, one more picture."
- [Regina] We were kinda distracted
by taking pictures the whole time,
that we didn't realize that...
This is a silent disco.
(disco music)
Each room had a different, deeper meaning.
- I think we uncovered it throughout.
We'd be like, "Oh, that's
cool, let's go look at it."
- [Regina] This is again-
- [Brandon] It's so cool.
- [Regina] Brandon's aesthetic.
- Dope.
And then we'd be like, "Oh, wait."
- [Regina] What is this?
That projection, right there, is me.
They made me into art.
The fuck? That's so cool.
I loved how every room was created
by a different artist.
- Even, we met some of the artists.
- And we got to learn a little
bit of their backstories.
We found the artist.
- The room is called
"The Future is Female."
It is in collaboration with Madame Gandhi,
and she's the musical artist.
We pulled lyrics from her song
and decorated all these
punching bags with them,
and then also added sensors in the bags.
So when you hit them,
they make sounds from her.
(loud thump)
- [Camera Man] Oh my god-
(laughs)
- [Brandon] Wow.
- Oh my god, I feel so powerful.
- It's a really good way-
(thump)
- [Regina] To let out anger?
- I'm a little scared of you.
(upbeat music)
We just walked in this giant
tent called "The Womb."
- [Regina] We are in the womb.
- [Brandon Voiceover] These
headphones are like a heartbeat,
and I feel like an actual baby.
- And that's the-
(Brandon laughs)
That's the thing we come out of.
One of my favorite ones
was called "Shred It,"
and it's basically writing down
whatever is weighing you down in life.
- [Brandon Voiceover] I wrote people.
I was low key kidding, and
putting it through the shredder
was a cool releasing experience.
Kind of release whatever
you were stressing about.
29Rooms is a lot more than
just a simple Instagram.
There was 29 totally
different experiences for us.
- Well, I did step up my Instagram game,
and Brandon took some
bomb-ass photos of me.
We were just having fun.
- [Brandon] Having a jolly good old time.
- I'm so happy.
I am so happy.
It was a nice way to appreciate
art and experience it.
Bye 29Rooms.
Instagram heaven rate was
- 29 out of 29.
- Would recommend.
- Do you think I say like,
"Thanks for watching," with you,
or just kind of end it?
- Thanks for watching. Subscribe and like.
No, yeah, we just end it.
Bye.
Ow, I don't think I can breathe.
- [Brandon] This would
be a good Boomerang.
Where's your phone?
(upbeat music)